since October 2007 the European Union
has been pursuing a brand new maritime
policy this innovative approach is
designed to remove the barriers between
the different sectors of activity and to
place a sustainable global vision at the
heart of all maritime initiatives this
radical change needs to be overseen and
co-ordinated properly as much by
decision-makers as regional national or
European players with the tools needed
to allow these various parties to work
hand-in-hand
what are we doing exploiting the
potential of the Seas and oceans in
order to make a significant and lasting
contribution to economic growth by
creating new jobs while better
respecting natural resources and the
marine environment this is what the
greatest maritime power in the world
calls an integrated maritime policy